>>> HAPPY WEEK 11 EVERYBODY.
"DRAFT KINGS LIVE."
I'M CONNER ROGERS AND THE MAN
NEXT TO ME IS SIZZLING HOT
BECAUSE HE WON HIS BOLD BET LAST
WEEK.
GREG, WE'RE GETTING CLOSE TO
THANKSGIVING.
HOW WE FEELING, MAN?
>> GETTING CLOSE TO THANKSGIVING
FEELING GOOD, CONNER, PEELING
GOOD, ACTUALLY FEELING SO GOOD
I'M GIVING AWAY A HOODIE RIGHT
NOW.
I GOT JJ SNELL IN THE COMMENTS.
HE'S GIVING US A KIRK COUSINS
GIFT.
HE'S DANCING.
SO HE'S FEELING GOOD.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU J.J. NAIL.
I'M FEELING GOOD.
CONNER, I HOPE YOU'RE FEELING
GOOD.
WE'RE ALL FEELING GOOD, MAN.
LET'S GET THIS ON THE ROAD,
CONNER.
>> I'M FEELING GREAT.
LET'S FIND THESE TOUCHDOWN
SCORES.
YOU KNOW THE DRILL BY NOW.
EVERY SINGLE WEEK, THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR.
WE ASKED YOU ON SOCIAL.
WE ASKED YOU IN THE APP.
THE END ZONE AS YOU SEE AT THE
TOP OF THE BOARD, NICK CHUBB
BACK AND READY TO RUMBLE AGAINST
A SOLID DEFENSE.
A.J. DILLON GETTING WORKHORSE
OPPORTUNITY WITH AARON JONES
BANGED UP AND OUT THIS WEEK.
JONATHAN TAYLOR SAVED US MANY,
MANY TIMES THERE YEAR.
C.D. LAMB, NO AMARI COOPER THIS
WEEK.
MORE TOUCHES FOR C.D. LAMB.
NEWTON MAKING HIS RETURN IN
CAROLINA EVERYBODY IS JACKED UP
FOR THAT AND DEREK CARR, WHAT
THE HECK IS HE DOING ON THE
BOARD PLUS 550.
>> HOW DID HE GET ON THE LIST?
>> THAT FEELS LIKE I GOT TO MAKE
MONEY TO BUY CHRISTMAS GIFTS FOR
MY RELATIVES QUICK.
LET'S SEE IF DEREK CARR CAN GET
HIS BUTT IN THE END ZONE.
LET'S LOOK AT SOME OF OUR
FAVORITE VIEDEOS LAST WEEK NOT
FEATURED ON THE SHOW.
>> THIS WEEK WE HAVE JONATHAN
TAYLOR, HARRIS, ALVIN KAMARA.
NINE TOUCHDOWNS.
FIRST TO THE GROUND WINS.
>> ABOUT TO GO BEAST MIND ON
THEM.
>> HERE WE GO.
GOT A WINNER.
>> ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN SCORE.
>> ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN JONATHAN
TAYLOR IS A LOCK.
>> GUARANTEED TOUCHDOWN THIS
SUNDAY.
>> LET'S GO.
>> THE LEGEND IS COMING IN HOLT.
WHAT ARE WE GIVING AWAY TODAY?
>> OUT ONLY HOODIES BUT GIVING
AWAY ONE -- NOT ONE, TWO, NFL
JERSEYS TODAY.
ONE GOES TO THE WINNING LEGEND
AND ANOTHER TO A LUCKY COMMENTER
LIKE YOU.
STAY TAPPED IN.
STAY TUNED.
DON'T GO ANYWHERE.
IF YOU WANT HOODIES AND JERSEYS,
I JUST NEED GIFTS.
I NEED EMOJIS BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY, WINNERS ONLY,
PLEASE.
TYPE THAT NOW.
>> LET'S GET IT DONE.
WE HAVE FOUR LEGENDARY PICKS TO
SHOW YOU.
YOU KNOW THE DRILL.
THE LAST ONE STANDING IS THE
"SQUAD RIDE" LEADER.
THEY GET THE TITLE TO BRING IN
THE NFL JERSEY.
WE'LL TRAIL THEM IF THEY LIKE
THAT PICK.
YOU KNOW THE DEAL BY NOW.
THE FIRST PITCH FROM JACK.
TELL US WHO IS SCORING A
TOUCHDOWN TODAY.
>> WHAT'S UP, GUYS?
MY NAME IS JACKSON AND IT'S
GUARANTEED MONEY CAM NEWTON
SCORES A TOUCHDOWN TOMORROW.
LET'S KEEP POUNDING.
>> JACKSON EXPLODING OUT OF THAT
SMEDIUM JERSEY.
RESPECT MY GUY WITH MUSCLE LOVE
THERE.
FIRST DECISION OF THE DAY.
WE GOT OUR SECOND PITCH FROM
MASTER SNEAKY.
WHEN IN DOUBT GO TO SNAPCHAT AND
ASK YOUR FRIENDS OR MAYBE FADE
YOUR FRIENDS.
LET'S SEE WHAT THEY GOT HERE.
>> YEAH.
>> GREG, DO YOU USE THIS?
I HAVEN'T USED SNAPCHAT IN A
LONG TIME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I WAS LITERALLY ABOUT TO SAY,
I DON'T THINK I'M A SNAPCHAT GUY
ANYMORE.
YOU KNOW YOUR BOY GALLOP IS
GOING TO SCORE.
HE'S ON MY FANTASY TEAM.
I ACTUALLY LIKE GALLOP SCORING
BUT LOOKS LIKE MY GUY, DID HE
FADE HIS GUY.
>> HE DID, HE GAVE HIM THE ROPE
AND DOPE.
HE SAID COOL, I'LL GO WITH THE
OTHER THING.
C.D. LAMB PLUS MONEY.
GREG AND I LIKE PLUS MONEY.
HOW ARE WE FEELING ABOUT THESE
RIGHT NOW?
>> I'M FEELING GOOD, CONNER.
WHAT I NEED THE PEOPLE TO DO IS
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME
IF WE SHOULD RIDE WITH THE
MUSCLE UP LEGEND OR THE SNAPCHAT
LEGEND, CAM NEWTON, C.D. LAMB,
LET'S TALK ABOUT IT.
WE HAVE CAM NEWTON FACING HIS
FORMER COACH RIVER BOAT RON IN
THE WASHINGTON FOOTBALL TEAM.
WE KNOW WHAT THE CAROLINA
PANTHERS LIKE TO DO WHEN THEY
GET IN THE RED ZONE WITH CAM
NEWTON, WE SAW IT LAST WEEK
POWER RIGHT, POWER LEFT WITH MY
BOY SUPERMAN CAM.
I LIKE THIS PLUS 120.
C.D. LAMB, NO AMARI COOPER, NO
AMARI COOPER.
WE KNOW ABOUT THE DALLAS OFFENSE
AND HOW POWERFUL THEY ARE.
CONNER, WHICH WAY ARE YOU
LEANING?
>> THESE ARE GREAT PICKS.
IF YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT IS COMING
AGAINST CAM NEWTON INSIDE THE
FIVE YARD LINE BUT NOW, YOU GOT
TO STOP IT AT SOME POINT.
YOU WOULD THINK RON RIVERA KNOWS
THAT, AS WELL.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, THE MAN
IS HARD TO ATTACK.
6'6" 240.
I'LL ROLL WITH C.D. LAMB.
THERE IS TEN, MAYBE 12 TARGETS
ON THE TABLE FOR HIM WITH NO
AMARI COOPER OUT.
THE CHIEF'S SECONDARY SCARES
NOBODY.
SO I LIKE C.D.
LET'S GET OUR FIRST DECISION OF
THE DAY FROM THE COMMENT
SECTION.
>> I AM IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT
NOW CONNER.
I'M NOT COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
AND I GOT AARON SHAM SAYS LAMB
IS THE MAN TODAY.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU CAN WALK AWAY WITH THE
HOODIE.
I GOT SASS SQUELCH SAYS CAM, CAM
THE MAN GOING TO LEAD THE LEAGUE
FOR ME.
HE'S ROCKING WITH CAM, CALE WILL
HELP HIM AND HIS FANTASY TEAM.
NEXT ONE I CHOOSE WE'LL ROCK
WITH IT, OKAY?
I HAVE -- I GOT ISAAC BOAT MAN,
ISAAC BOAT MAN SAYS LAMB HE'S
JUST COMMENTING LAMB SO MANY
TIMES.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU ISAAC BOAT MAN.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
IT APPEARS WE'RE MOVING ON WITH
C.D. LAMB AND THE SNAPCHAT
LEGEND.
YOU'RE MOVING ON.
>> MASTER SNEAKY WITH C.D. LAMB
MOVING TO ROUND NUMBER TWO BUT
GOT A WAYS TO GO.
ALL RIGHT.
NEXT PITCH, WHO IS SCORING A
TOUCHDOWN TODAY?
>> WHAT'S UP, BR BETTING?
GOT TO MAKE THIS QUICK.
ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN SCORE LOCK OF
THE WEEK, SOME PEOPLE THEY GO TO
FORTUNE TERMS, SOME PEOPLE USE A
MAGIC EIGHT BALL.
I USE A MAG JIC BULL.
NEVER WRONG.
SEE WHAT IT GIVES US.
A.J. DILLON, LOCK IT IN.
LET'S WIN TOGETHER.
>> THE MAGIC BULLET LEGEND GOING
WITH THE NEW WORKHORSE IN A.J.
DILLON.
THAT MAN IS READY TO RUMBLE
EVERY SINGLE WEEK AND HE'S GOING
TO HAVE A LOT OF TOUCHES.
THIS IS MINUS HERE.
WE'RE GOING MINUS 125 AND STILL
HAVE C.D. LAMB AT THE PLUS
MONEY.
THIS WILL BE INTERESTING.
EVERYBODY LOVES THE RUNNING
BACKS UNTIL THE END ZONE.
YOU KNOW THE GUY NEXT TO ME AND
GREG LIKES TO GET THESE BOOSTED
UP INTO PLUS MONEY.
DOES THIS CHANGE YOUR MIND AT
ALL HERE, GREG?
>> CONNER, THIS ONE IS TOUGH.
THIS IS TOUGH.
BUT LET ME TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
I NEED YOU GUYS TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME ARE YOU
ROCKING WITH A.J. DILLON AND THE
MAGIC BULLET OR SNAPCHAT LEGEND
IN C.D. LAMB?
LET'S TALK ABOUT A.J. DILLON.
WE KNOW THE GREEN BAY PACKERS
LIKE TO RUN THE BALL TO GET
AARON ROGERS GOING BUT I JUST
DON'T KNOW IF I WANT TO ROCK
WITH A.J. DILLON OVER C.D. LAMB.
C.D. LAMB IS PLUS MONEY.
YOU KNOW WE CAN JUST BOOST THAT
UP.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING?
YOU LIKE DILLON OR C.D. LAMB?
>> BOTH BUT I'LL ROLL WITH C.D.
LAMB.
I THINK THE COWBOYS WILL PUT UP
A LOT OF POINTS.
I THINK MINNESOTA GETS HOT AND
COLD THAT DEFENSE AND A.J.
DILLON IS A GOOD BET BECAUSE
HE'S GOT NO OTHER BACKS AROUND
HIM TO TAKE AWAY CARRIES BUT FOR
ME, I'M GOING TO STICK WITH WHAT
WORKS NOW AND C.D. LAMB IS GOING
TO BE THAT DUDE THIS WEEK BUT
THE COMMENTS GET THE ULTIMATE
SAY IN THIS.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT DIRECTION
THEY'RE GOING HERE, GREG.
>> COMMENTS DEFINITELY GETS THE
ULTIMATE SAY.
I DON'T THINK I INTRODUCED THE
HANDY DANDY BUT THIS HERE IS THE
HANDY DANDY.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS, CONNER, I
AM IN THE COMMENTS.
I SEE DILLON AND I WANT TO WIN
SAYS DILLON TO CARRY THAT ROCK.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWIT
AY WITH A
HOODIE.
A.J. DILLON IS A LOCK.
CONNER, I'LL CALL IT THERE.
YOU WANT TO CALL IT THERE?
KEEP IT SHORT, SWEET AND CONCISE
AND THE MAGIC BULLET LEGEND, YOU
ARE MOVING ONTO THE NEXT ROUND.
>> THE MAGIC BULLET LEGEND
MOVING ON.
SO A.J. DILLON GETTING LOTS OF
LOVE HERE.
WE HAVE ONE MORE ROUND.
THIS IS FOR THE TITLE SQUAD RIDE
LEADER.
WE WERE TRAILING, ALSO FOR THE
NFL JERSEY AND STICK AROUND
AFTER THAT BECAUSE GREG HAS GOT
A LITTLE MORE.
HE'S GOT ANOTHER NFL JERSEY, 20
HOODIES TO GIVE AWAY AND A FINAL
ROUND.
WE BROUGHT IN A FAMILIAR FACE, A
F
FAMILIAR CONTENDER IN W.
W. TRAMMEL.
LET'S SEE WHAT YOU GOT.
>> WHAT'S UP, BR NATION?
LET'S SEE WHO WE GET NICK CHUBB.
LOCK IT IN.
>> THE LEGEND GOING WITH NICK
CUC
CHUBB MINUS 165.
MY FAVORITE PICK OF THE DAY IF
YOU CAN GET THAT TO EVEN MONEY.
NICK CHUBB WILL HAVE A FIELD DAY
AGAINST THE TEAM.
THE ONLY THING YOU GOT TO WORRY
ABOUT IS THEM WATCHING HIS LOAD
MANAGEMENT AT THAT POINT.
NOT GIVING HIM ENOUGH CARRIES IF
THEY REST AND GET UP EN COMPETI.
WE HAVE TWO RUNNING BACKS, TWO
MONSTER RUNNING BACKS THAT GET
IT DONE IN THE RED ZONE TIME AND
TIME AGAIN.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE ONES WHERE
YOU CAN FLIP A COIN AND PICK
EITHER WAY.
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE DOING HERE,
GREG, OR DO YOU FEEL STRONGLY
ABOUT A CERTAIN GUY?
>> CONNER, LET ME TALK TO THE
PEOPLE IN THE COMMENTS FIRST.
WHAT I NEED YOU GUYS TO DO MOST
IMPORTANT IS COMMENT, LET US
KNOW ARE WE ROCKING WITH A.J.
LEGEND OR NICK CHUBB.
>> CONNER, I LIKE NICK C
HUBB
BECAUSE HE'S FACING THE DETROIT
LIONS DEFENSE.
THEY DON'T SCARE ANYBODY.
WE KNOW WHAT THE BROWNS LIKE TO
DO.
BAKER MAYFIELD -- WE DON'T EVEN
KNOW IF HE'S PLAYING OR HURT.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, WE KNOW
THEY'RE GOING TO BOUND THE ROCK
SO I LIKE THIS PICK.
YOU SAID IT'S YOUR FAVORITE
PICK.
IT'S MY FAVORITE PICK.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE CAN DO.
I SEE IT'S MINUS 165 BUT YOU
KNOW WE'RE GOING TO BOOST THAT
UP.
CONNER, YOU LIKE IT, RIGHT?
.
YOU'RE IN ON THE NICK C
HUBB
TRAIN, RIGHT?
>> I NEED THEM TO PUSH THIS
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE.
GREG AND I ONLY HAVE SO MUCH SAY
WHO WINS.
LET'S GET NICK CHUBB TO PLUS
MONEY.
GREG, IS THAT ENOUGH TO GET THIS
ONE AS "THE SQUAD RIDE" LEADER?
>> IT MIGHT BE ENOUGH.
IT MIGHT BE ENOUGH.
WE HAVE GOLDIE LOCKS IN THE
COMMENTS SAYS CHUBB TOUCHES
FIRST GAME BACK MEANING HE'S
GOING TO SCORE A TOUCHDOWN.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU GOLDIE LOCKS,
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I GOT ONE -- I GOT ONE ANOTHER.
PX 1 SAYS CHUBB SAYS HE HAS A
GIFT OF A LITTLE KID DANCING.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
CONNER, DO I GIVE AY A JERSEY
HERE?
DO I GIVE AWAY A JERSEY HERE?
NO JERSEY.
>> FOR "THE SQUAD RIDE" LEADER
YOU CAN GIVE AWAY THE JERSEY.
>> OKAY.
OKAY.
OKAY, OWE.
NO JERSEY HERE.
OKAY.
I'LL GIVE IT AWAY.
I'LL GIVE IT AWAY LATER.
>> KEEP THEM WAITING.
>> BUT I'LL KEEP IT WAITING BUT
CONNER, I THINK IT'S APPARENT IF
YOU LOOK IN THE COMMENTS, NICK
CHUBB IS RUNNING AWAY.
WE'RE GOING TO CALL IT HERE.
NICK CHUBB IS TH"THE SQUAD RIDE
LEADER THIS WEEK.
LET'S PUT UP THE GRAPHIC SO I
CAN SHOW YOU WHAT WE CAN DO
HERE.
MINUS 165.
POOF.
THERE IT IS.
THAT'S THE MAGIC THAT WE CAN DO.
WE JUST BOOSTED IT UP.
WE TOOK IT FOR 165 TO PLUS 100.
SHOUTOUT TO OUR FRIENDS AT DRAFT
KINGS WHO BOOSTED THE ODDS FOR
US.
CHECK BR BETTING SOCIALS FOR A
LINK TO THE ODDS BOOST.
SEND US YOUR SCREEN SHOT AND
BET.
LET'S GET RICH THIS SUNDAY
EVERYBODY.
SEND US YOUR VIDEOS AND
CELEBRATIONS BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY, WE WANT WINNERS AND
WINNERS ONLY, PLEASE.
>> THAT IS WELL DONE, MY FRIEND.
THOSE ARE GREAT ODDS FROM NICK
C
CHUBB TO GET IN THE END ZONE.
COMMUNITY COMMENT CONTEST TIME.
THIS WEEK WE ASKED YOU A SIMPLE
ONE.
WOULD YOU BET $100 ON THE
PANTHERS THOSE REINVIGORATED
PANTHERS WITH CAM BACK IN THE
BUILDING.
WOULD YOU BET $100 ON THEM TO
MAKE PLAYOFFS?
WE ASK YOU FOR YOUR BEST
COMMENTS AND FOUND TWO OF THEM
AND NOW IT'S A CONTEST.
WE WANT TO SEE THE WINNER AND
THE WINNER TAKES HOME THE
HOODIE.
WHAT DO WE GOT FROM THE COMMENTS
THIS WEEK?
>> I NEED YOU GUYS TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL US WHICH OF
THESE IS THE BETTER TAKE?
I'M GIVING A HOODIE TO WHOEVER
YOU CHOOSE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE FIRST
COMMENT FROM TEAM PSYCHOTIC 24.
SAYS CAN'T WAIT FOR THIS HEART
FELT REUNION TO CRASH BACK TO
EARTH.
THERE IS A REASON THEY LET THEM
GO IN THE FIRST PLACE.
HE'S WATCHED PLAYING AND SIMPLE
WOW THIS ONE IS A BURN.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE'S WASHED BUT
CONNER, WHAT IS YOUR TAKE?
IS CAM NEWTON WASHED?
>> IF HE'S NOT 2015 CAM, MVP
CAM, WE DON'T WANT HIM.
SAM DARNOLD WAS HORRIFIC FOR THE
PANTHERS AFTER A COUPLE GOOD
GAMES.
THIS IS AN UPGRADE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S BIG ENOUGH
I'M CARRYING ALL MY CASH TO THE
BOOK AND BETTING ON THE PANTHERS
TO MAKE THE PLAYOFFS SO WITH
THAT BEING SAID, I THINK IT'S A
LITTLE HARSH BUT AT THE SAME
TIME, I FEEL IT.
WHAT ELSE WE GOT IN STORE HERE?
WE GOT ONE MORE IN OUR POCKETS.
>> LET'S SEE THE NEXT COMMENT
FROM INGLEWOOD.
SAYS IT'S ONLY RIGHT THEY MAKE
IT TO THE SUPER BOWL, WHOA,
WHOWHO
WHOA, WHOA.
ARE YOU ON THE TRAIN FOR THAT
SUPER BOWL?
>> NICE STORY LINE EVERYBODY
WOULD LOVE TO SEE.
THE TEAM THAT CUT KNEW TNEWTON
THE GAME, NOBODY WAS EXPECTING
THIS MATCHUP TO NECESSARILY
HAPPEN BUT I LIKE THE VIBE AND
HA
HATERADI.
D
DO THE PEOPLE HAVE A FAVORABLE
SIDE?
>> LET ME HOP IN HERE.
I SEE LATROY JAMES IS CALLING
HIM A HATER.
YEAH, WE APPRECIATE THE COMMENT.
WE APPRECIATE THE COMMENT.
>> WE ALWAYS DO.
>> CAM NEWTON IS ABOUT TO GO OFF
TODAY.
WATCH THE HATERS WILL REMEMBER
MY WORK.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
LATROLL JAMES SAYS AGREE, GOING
TO BE 2015 CAM AGAIN.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I'M GOING TO MAKE THE DECISION
HERE, CONNER.
I'M JUST GOING TO MAKE A
DECISION.
I LIKE INGLEWOOD FOR THE VIBES.
JUST FOR THE GOOD VIBES.
I LIKE INGLEWOOD M.B. SAID MY
BOY CAM IS GOING TO THE SUPER
BOWL TAKING ON MACK JONES AND
THE PATRIOTS.
WHAT A TIME.
I MEAN, WHAT A TIME IF THAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENS, WHAT A TIME.
SO INGLEWOOD YOU ARE WALKING
AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
>> YEAH, THIS IS A FEEL GOOD
SHOW SO WE HAD TO GO WITH THE
FEEL GOOD COMMENT.
BEFORE WE GET OUT OF HERE, IT'S
TIME FOR OUR BOLDEST BETS AND
YOU GOT THE HOT HAND RIGHT NOW,
GREG, ZEKE ELLIOTT GETTING IN
THE END ZONE NOT ONCE BUT TWICE
LAST WEEK.
I HOPE PEOPLE TRAILED YOU ON
THAT ONE AND MADE A LOT OF
MONEY.
I'M EXCITED TO HEAR WHAT YOU GOT
NEXT WEEK.
WHAT DO WE NEED RIGHT NOW?
>> I NEED THE PEOPLE TO GET IN
THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME IF
YOU'RE RIDING WITH ME OR CONNER.
CONNER, LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT,
MAN.
KEEP IT SHORT, SWEET AND
CONCISE.
WHAT ARE YOU TAKING, BROTHER?
>> LOOKING FOR TOUCHDOWN SCORES
AGAIN AND TAKING A PAGE OUT OF
YOUR PLAYBOOK AND LOOKING AT THE
DALLAS OFFENSE.
WE HAD HIM EARLIER IN THE SHOW
C.D. LAMB, MICHAEL GALLOP FINDS
HIS WAY THERE AND DAK CAN THROW
THREE TO FOUSR TOUCHDOWNS EVERY
WEEK.
C.D., WIDE RECEIVER WON FOR
THEM.
THE MAN CAN PLAY PLUS 700 ON
THIS, GREG.
JUICY ODDS.
I'LL WATCH DALLAS CLOSELY.
YOU HAVE THE HOT HAND COMING
INTO THIS.
WHAT ARE YOU BRINGING THIS WEEK?
>> CONNER, I DID SEE ONE GO
THROUGH THE HOOP LAST WEEK.
LOVE YOUR PLAY, BY THE WAY,
BROTHER.
I GOT MICHAEL GALLOP ON MY
FANTASY TEAM.
ALSO SCORING TODAY.
BUT LET'S TAKE IT, LET'S TAKE IT
OVER TO THE NEW YORK GIANTS,
TAMPA BAY GAME.
THE TOTAL INTERCEPTIONS IS
SITTING AT 2.5 AND THIS IS A
COMBINED INTERCEPTION SO TOM
BRADY AND DANNY DIMES, WE KNOW
WHAT IS PLAYING QUARTERBACK FOR
THE GIANTS.
I SAID HIS NAME DANNY DIMES.
HE'S FACING THE TAMPA BAY
BUCCANEERS DEFENSE SO I CAN SEE
DANNY DIMES FLIPPING SOME COINS,
FLIPPING SOME INTERCEPTIONS AND
TOM BRADY HAS BEEN STRUGGLING
LATELY.
BEEN STRUGGLING LATELY.
TOM MAYBE CAN FLIP ONE, MAYBE
TWO.
WHO KNOWS.
BUT I THINK THE TOTAL WILL GO
OVER 2.5 INTERCEPTIONS IN THAT
BALL GAME TODAY.
PLUS 300.
I LIKE IT.
>> I LOVE THAT PLAY.
WE'LL GET TWO INTERCEPTIONS OUT
OF DANIEL JONES AND ONE OUT OF
THE GO IN TOM BRADY AND THEN YOU
CASH YOUR TICKET.
THAT'S A GREAT PLAY THIS WEEK.
ALL RIGHT.
GREG, WE NEED TWO THINGS BEFORE
WE GET OUT OF HERE.
WHO ARE THE PEOPLE RIDING WITH
US?
TWO, YOU STILL HAVE ON NFL
JERSEY GIFT CARD TO GIVE AWAY.
>> SO NOW -- SO YOU'RE TELLING
ME NOW --
>> YEAH!
TIME TO GET RID OF IT, YEAH.
>> OKAY.
I'M IN THE JERSEY.
CHRIS PAUL SAYS CONNER IS A
LOCK.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
NFL JERSEY.
>> GOOD VIBES.
>> BECAUSE YOU SHOUTED OUT MY
CO-HOST.
>> RESPECT.
>> CONNER IS A LEGEND AND HE'S A
LOCK.
HE'S A WALKING LOCK, ACTUALLY.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS NOW CONNER
GIVING AWAY HOODIES.
I'M SEEING LOVE GREG ALL THE
WAY.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU JERSEY OR BUST.
APPRECIATE YOU.
CONNER DOESN'T MISS.
WHITE SOX LET IT RIDE.
THEY KNOW WHAT TO DO.
THEY'RE BUTTERING US UP.
>> YEAH, I WAS GOING TO SAY --
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> "THE SQUAD RIDE" IS MY
BANKROLL UP.
THAT'S THE ONLY THING KEEPING
THE BANKROLL UP.
>> THAT'S A FACT, BRO.
WE'VE BEEN HITTING.
I WANT TO GIVE AWAY ONE MORE
HOODIE.
LET ME TRY TO FIND SOMEBODY.
I GOT JOSE BURRITO.
DALLAS WILL BLOW KANSAS OUT AND
THE PANTHERS WILL BEAT
WASHINGTON.
I LOVE THE TAKE.
SO JOSE, YOU'RE WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
>> BOLD TAKE.
BAKER MAYFIELD, I DON'T KNOW IF
HE WAS RULED OUT WHILE WE WERE
DOING THE SHOW OR WHAT.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO PLAY
THROUGH SOME PAIN BUT LOVE THEM
PICKING UNDER DOGS.
ALL RIGHT, EVERYONE, GOOD LUCK
WITH YOUR WAGERS.
CONGRATS TO THE HOODIE AND
JERSEY WINNERS.
YOU KNOW THE DEAL, IF YOU WON BR
BETTING WILL REACH OUT TO YOU
OVER THE NEXT 24 HOURS.
HAVE NO FEAR.
YOU'LL GET YOUR GEAR.
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE THAT
COMMENTED AND THANK YOU TO THE
LEGENDS ROCKING THAT SMEDIUM.
W. TRAMMEL SWOOPING IN AT THE
END TAKING HOME THE TITLE WITH
THE SQUAD RIDE TITLE.
FOLLOW US, FOLLOW GREG ON THE IG
STORIES ALL DAY.
HE'S ALWAYS BRINGING GOOD VIBES,
GOOD ENERGY, A LONG SIDE THE HOT
HAND GREG IVORY, I'M CONNER
ROGERS.
GREG, I WAS WAITING FOR YOU TO
CUT ME OFF AND GIVE AWAY ANOTHER
HOD
HOODIE.
>> GREAT FOR A DALLAS COWBOY FAN
LIKE ME AND FOR DALLAS COWBOY
FAN LIKE ME, LET'S GO COWBOYS.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU 22 GOLDIE.
LITTLER TIME 100 SAYS LET ME GET
A GOODY.
I'M A REAL ONE FOR STAYING.
>> YOU ARE A REAL ONE FOR
STAYING AND YOU GET A HOODIE.
>> YOU IS WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
>> SEE YA NEXT WEEK, SAME TIME,
SAME PLACE, EVERYONE.
♪